can you think about the last fad
that went away was explosive
and it went away and we forgot about it
last fad like financial fad or fashion
fed financial fat any kind of fat that
came
and left like the starter jackets that
matt likes to write okay but give me a
fad that came a little bit
think about think about the financial
fads or any fact
it was explosive and then left us aol
okay and some messengers i think that's
technology but fine
jeans baggy jeans like i'm talking about
cavalry
just think about okay give me a fad that
came and left huh
okay came and left fads fans
if you're watching this do you remember
fads that came
and left okay came and left mario go to
the fat
side i just sent you because i want to
make a point to you okay
so here's the fads in the last go to
view gallery
40 fads oh i i got something because i
wore it the other day
what's that he wore affliction what's a
[ __ ] flicker
oh my god t-shirts affliction it was the
biggest thing
perfect yeah he wore it the other day i
was like bro what are you living in he
had a haircut the other day i think him
and paul went to the same barber but
that's a hair galera
okay go to the fats hacky sack 1980s
yeah when's the last time you saw a
hacky sound go your kid's playing with
hector
hippie a hippie party garbage pail kids
i don't even remember that
that was my card okay 1980s wrestling
now you can't forget i don't think it's
a fan jelly shoes
adam you have jelly shoes no no you
don't want the crux there's no belt okay
are smurfs of fat or do people still
collect smurfs i don't know about this
okay keep going eighties remember these
things i remember these things okay keep
going somebody's like tight tight toes
care about care bears
okay what's your favorite thing is it
still here or no it is a sales
organization
[Laughter]
is it still is it a fat or is it still
here i think it's still here
okay keep going keep going gangster
keep going but not house music house
music is here to stay
cabbage by the way go back to boombox
sam order a nice boombox
for us order one of those 80s boom boxes
keep going keep going
cabbage mats patch kids is it is it a
fat or is it still here
cabbage cabbage how about furby just
gone
gone okay keep going for sure gizmo
it's still here it's back you were
considering buying a merch i would buy
i would buy a crust there's a name for
it it's called the cross
uh crust let's go across um
there's a name for it the the if you put
uh if you cross your body
no there's a name for this man purse the
fanny pack was for a cd player
is that where you would put it your
walkman yellow headphones to your sony
walkman that's a fad what were those
a fanny pack waterproof sony walkman
crossbody
crossbody okay crossbody keep going
overalls fat
uh by the way did you ever wear it
though of course it's yours
with one arm
that's very crisscross
mark wahlberg yeah if you think about it
okay how about pogs anybody remembers
pods
i mean i remember pogba in high school
right but when's the last time you saw
pogs
push pops remember push pops yes okay
keep going
polly pocket i can't see you having a
polly pocket
okay temporary tattoos no everyone's
doing the real ones on their faces okay
that's a good point
spice girls a couple of them are still
in fashion yeah
jinko jeans yeah by the way mario
did you ever have jinko jeans who here
wore jinko jeans anybody ever did you
wear gingko
hello did you really okay baggiest jeans
on the planet how long did jinko jeans
last
a solid five years a solid five years
like 95 to 2
000 if you wear jinko jeans right now
what will people say bro get what are
you wearing hiding a shotgun in your
pants
like what are you doing butterfly clips
mario ways to wear those i've got
daughters so it's still in still in
really okay keep going keep going live
strong well
i mean this this was a definitely for
different reasons yeah big time
correct keep going okay energy drinks
between pat
uh paul and mario they keep them in
business i think energy drinks are still
around i don't think
are you still seeing flash mobs
happening no okay keep going
what else we got high school musical not
since zac efron left
okay keep going uh mario keep going
myspace
fat friends hardcore fan digital cameras
and lindsay lohan fast wow
shout out to the mean girls out there
wow von dutch this is very
afflictionesque
one season razor scooters do you still
see those i just kids
yeah okay so we see the bratz dolls no
these things i never liked it's kind of
like you know what are you trying to
promote here to young girls you know
oh i see what you're saying oversized
sunglasses
fat or still people doing it uh no kim k
uh those are gone cronuts dude what
cronus like a croissant doughnut what's
a cronut i guess that's what it is
okay remember coney this thing lasted
for 90 days
i don't know if you remember this do you
know why it stopped though
do you know why it's stuff do you know
the story or no no we'll go research it
for yourself so this guy got caught
doing something in the street and the
cops got him gotcha
and and it's it's a pretty i remember
extracurricular activity that young boys
do a lot of so
2010 flower crowns okay
keep going meyer's got some clothes
harlem shake dance remember that
of course lebron and chris bosh and all
those guys won the best ones
fidget spinners i still got them okay
keep going
shutter shave for sure fed go yeah next
internet challenge still going what's
the challenge or still going on no more
we got a busted challenge got to keep
going challenge dress debate
what is a dress debate pokemon oh still
going
keep going tiny sunglasses okay i don't
know about our friend marcelo still
rockstar
so here's the question here's a question
a real question when's the last time we
had a financial investment fad
when is the last time we had a financial
investment fat bitcoin
is it a fad or is it here to stay i
think it's here to stay
okay what give me give me so the tech
boom of the late 90s
sold a an nft a digital picture for 69
million
dollars crazy okay and you know where
you store it
in your phone phone you can't put it up
and show it to people you can't say oh
on this wall here let me show you
here's what's supposed to be there you
don't see it it's just a white wall but
let me tell you what's really good
because it's digital you just don't see
it but i want you to appreciate this
digital thing that you cannot see yeah
so is it a fad or is it here to stay
are nft or are crypto blockchain
cards videos highlights of lebron nfts
are they here to stay i think they're
here to stay mainly because there's a
way for the artist in the detainer or
the creator but to still monetize the
royalties
i still i think it's here to stay i
think it's going to revolutionize
um that income source for something that
the digital music uh and digital
entertainment took away
i think okay fair enough adam what would
you say i think anything with the word
digital in it
is pretty much not going anywhere okay
right so you're saying nfts are here to
stay
i think something that you always talk
about is your picasso story
about the guy he went in and got the
picture with the picasso and then he
fabricated it and then oh look at the
last picasso
and this you know enables that not to
happen yeah so
but also part of art and part of
baseball cards
is look at this it's on the wall check
it out take a look guys
feel my card this is like what do you
pull up my phone go to realtor.com go to
realtor.com
go to realtor.com go to boca raton
filter five miles
uh go value five to ten million dollars
okay type in boca raton i'm gonna show
you something
so homes today you go see them what's
the typical style homes you see today
today like newly built homes like more
mediterranean or more modern more modern
yeah okay
so if you go to uh price just go to
price and go put
five million and up go 5 million and up
i've been here for 24 hours
just put five and keep putting zeros six
zeroes
yeah one more okay there you go just
search okay that's okay and up
so go and just press enter click any
price so i call boca raton to land we
can just spend stupid money
so so then go to go to the first one
go to the first one at the top click on
that
go inside of it oh mario we just looked
at this house it's crazy we just
okay that's exactly the house okay this
house was built one mario you and i just
looked at this house last week okay
this house was built when 2001. right
click on the image to get bigger now
let's go inside the house keep going i
like how to put the
va loan zero down mortgage veterans go
buy this thing let's go inside the house
let's go inside the house mario go
inside mario inside the house bro
okay watch this see those pillars those
pillars yeah that's one
that's not today oh one you don't see
pillars today like that
those pillars the four pillars that's
one look at those pillars
look at the floor mark it's beautiful
it's timeless but it's 0-1 keep going
keep going like this you don't see a lot
of this today
keep going okay go go back up go back up
elevator
go back up not that much mario just two
back up buddy just
okay go back down to where we were with
the image
oh my god keep going down go to the sink
the green sink you're three away it's
perfect
right there right there that's that's
old school you don't see that today
okay that color stone is what we're
talking about the sink like the
the where you wash your hands yeah you
do see that but maybe not not that color
today keep
you see the mirror you don't see that
mirror today go up a little bit you
don't see that mirror today go a little
lower to the wine cellar you don't
necessarily see the bricks like that
today you do but not all the time okay
so mediterranean homes are a fad
to people today today it's more modern
so if you saw back in old one that was a
fad
that so that's a fad now the kitchen
they upgraded look at that that's a
north kitchen yeah
that's not an one kitchen i can
guarantee that was built in the last 12
months to increase the value of the
house
look how modern that looks it was a
gorgeous kitchen look at that
yeah they spent a quarter million
dollars in that kitchen one thing i
don't like about it the kitchen you
as you're cooking you're facing the wall
i like having a kitchen you're facing
everybody
i agree with you i agree with you so but
the point is
this is a fad fashion fads
investment fads some people thought
bitcoin was a fad
but it's here today and it's not just
here today
it ain't going away okay it's popping
and they just made a prediction saying
this one guy made a prediction saying by
2023 bitcoins are going to be what five
trillion dollars
and by 2030 market cap 20 20 30 is
predicting it's going to be
20 trillion dollars today it's about 1.2
trillion dollars
so that means it's kind of forex in the
next two years and it's going to roughly
9x in the next
10 years nine years right bitcoin is not
going away
are digital cards going to go away no
now we're how old
at this table everybody starts number
four right starts with the number four
forty
sepala is forty two you're forty two
forty two stages and backwards so but
you come to a house
i wanna see a nice painting on the wall
i like that
does dylan like the paintings on the
wall in your house not so much come on
dude
why dylan
you like the sound it's so funny at this
house why do you hate this house
why is there so many naked paint limit
on
amount of naked ladies on your wall not
that you painted them life-sized too
listen i i obviously can't invite my
pastor to my say can we have a bible
study at the house you know come on do
it in the backyard we're not gonna
don't come in don't come in
the point i'm trying to make is i don't
think it's a fad i think it's huge
okay i don't think it's a fad i think
people have to respect it and have to
understand that there's gonna be a lot
of money
being made with nfts i like to hold the
card i just got a one soto i just showed
you the black label
i like to hold roots card that i have
that you know i like to hold
chamberlain's rookie card joe dimaggio's
rookie card ted williams i like to hold
these cards zion williamson
three out of five you know national
treasures i like to hold that
one yeah but there's not a major
difference between holding the card and
holding your phone where the card is no
it's a difference it's the same so
people what's the smart money though
okay you're talking about a 69 million
dollar nft
if i'm a typical guy watching this right
now what's the smart money there what's
the smart money play
the money smart platform oh yeah you you
just have to know msm it's
don't get don't get emotionally tied to
investments
don't yeah don't get emotionally tied to
investments
you know be logical when it's coming to
investments like whether you agree with
it or not it's not going away
it's here to stay so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye